[Music]
welcome to supercharged or gke
development workflows with ID extensions
my name is Ian hi everyone I'm eight-ton
before we get started we'll do a little
quick about us yeah so my name is Aiden
I've been at Google for about three
years now I work on the Google cloud
platform currently I'm the technical
lead for cloud code for IntelliJ and in
my spare time I enjoy traveling and
doing some snowboarding and my name is
Ian I also work on Google cloud platform
I've been there about six years and I'm
based out of Seattle I I'm the technical
lead for cloud code for Visual Studio
code which is a partner effort to what
aton is working on I also like to travel
but instead of pictured my dog here who
I think's adorable so cloud code taught
and I both said it what is it so cloud
code is a set of integrated tooling that
aims to make working with kubernetes and
cloud native applications easier we want
to make that development process simpler
we know it's hard we've seen people work
with it they struggle there's a lot of
moving pieces you have your yamo you
have
worrying about the statefulness of your
application and then your code so what
we've done is we've tried to break it up
and do a couple different portions we
kind of have something for the
developers and we have people on the
DevOps side and we understand that
there's overlap and of course you'll
probably end up using both parts of
these tooling but what we have for the
developers so who in the audience here
your primary job is writing code your
developer show of hands all right a lot
of developers here good so we got some
good stuff for you so what we try and do
is we understand that working with
kubernetes means you have to work with a
cluster but a lot of the times you just
want to be writing code so to make it
easier we try and make it as as close as
possible to your local development
experience so when you're working with
your code you're writing code and in the
background we handle building your image
building your application pushing it off
to your gke cluster or your kubernetes
cluster whatever you're working with and
it's there when you're ready to check it
out and work with it on top of that we
debug in we've tried to simplify that we
make it easy if you have a pod selector
you can very simply just debug a remote
cluster no problem at all and then on
the DevOps side who's your a little more
on the DevOps side all right we've got a
lot of DevOps in here too you'll get to
see some pretty cool
teachers so we give you some support in
the IDE to help you understand the state
of your application see what things are
live and what's not if there's issues
view events that have happened recently
and on top of that easily diagnose
issues you can use the debugging but
also look into the logs and other things
we also give some great tooling to help
making the yamo a little easier to
consume and able to go back and forth
from what's local on your machine the
yam what you have there against the
server yam oh so Aton now is gonna give
us a little bit deeper dive into some of
the features we have to offer alright
thanks again so before we look a little
bit closer to some of the features that
cloud code has to offer just to get an
idea of what people here are using in
the room if I could get a show of hands
how many people here use vs code on a
regular basis and what about JetBrains
are one of the other JetBrains itthere
IntelliJ based IDs okay cool and then
what about something else some other
editor makes sense all right so let's
take a closer look at some of the
features of cloud code for IDs so first
of all the inner development loop what
is that
so imagine that you're tasked with
building an application or a micro
service that needs to run on a
kubernetes cluster one of the first
things you might want to do after
figuring out basic tasks like firing up
your favorite editor setting a version
control and so on is actually running
your application so opening up a web
browser hitting the endpoint assuming
it's a web app and then verifying and
making sure that everything works as
intended and then iterating on your code
so in other words setting up that inner
development loop now since your
application is going to be deployed to a
kubernetes cluster it's probably pretty
important that your development
environment mayor production as closely
as possible this means running on an
actual cluster now this could be a local
cluster like mini cube or a cluster on
docker for desktop or if you have the
resources available to you it could be
one on a remote cluster on one of the
cloud providers like gke
on GCP
right so if you've ever tried to set up
this process manually you know it's not
such an easy task you have to figure out
how to build your container image tag it
push it to a container repository update
your manifests deploy everything and
then repeat this every time you change
your code all of this while you're
trying to focus on writing your code in
getting your business logic working
properly so we think the IDE is a good
place to try and tackle some of these
problems because we all know that
context switching can really kill
productivity so our tooling will help
here we'll create new targets for you in
the IDE and form of new commands in the
command palette if you're a V s code
user and new run configurations if
you're an intelligent the single click
setup this development workflow so the
tooling will take care of building
building the image pushing it up to a
repository deploying your application
and the tooling will sit there and watch
for changes in your source code and then
surface it live on a cluster every time
something changes so you can quickly
verify your code and again let me stress
this can be any kubernetes cluster so it
can be a local development cluster or it
can work on any of the cloud providers
and when you're done with development
the tooling will take care of cleaning
up the deployed artifacts for you so
much like the feel of a local
development server but with the power
and the fidelity of running on a real
kubernetes cluster alright next
debugging so at some point inevitably
you're going to run into issues with
your application at this point is
probably really important that you be
able to set up a debugger so this means
setting breakpoints stepping through
your code reviewing the call stack local
variables being able to run expressions
and so on but remember our application
now is running inside of a container and
on the cluster somewhere so setting this
up manually is not really that trivial
you have to setup the proper language
specific debug configuration inject that
properly setting up the environment
variables doing the port forwarding and
attaching a remote debugger our tooling
will help here again with a single click
you'll be able to set up a debugger and
attach it to your service or even your
set of my
services and debug your application as
easily as if it were running locally
cool so now you can set up your
development workflow and you can debug
your code one thing at this point that
might be interesting to do is gain some
insight into the state of your cluster
so this means digging down into the
resources checking to see if your pods
are healthy
maybe streaming logs from a container or
even viewing remotely amyl to make sure
things are there as you expect them and
our tooling again will help here in the
form of in an IDE resource browser so at
some point you're gonna want to expand
your application add more features add
more functionality and this probably
means more configuration more llamó
our tools will help you work with this
by providing templates and editing
support so things like Auto completion
and quick documentation all the things
you'd expect from an editing editing
experience inside of an IDE we also have
integrations with popular tools and
libraries a couple examples first
scaffold scaffold powers much of the
inner loop experience in the deployment
that I talked about and in the demo
you'll see us dig in a little bit into
the configuration there
Jib you'll see this in the demo to Jib
stands for java image builder so for
your java developers out there jib is a
tool that helps you easily containerize
your java applications you don't need to
have docker installed you don't even
need to write a docker file all you need
to do is drop in a snippet into your
pom.xml or your build.gradle depending
on what you're using lastly we have some
key integrations with the Google cloud
but with Google cloud platform products
and I'll give a couple examples so the
first one is an API browser in the demo
use you'll see that we're going to be
using the Google cloud vision API to
extract some features from a book image
with the API browser inside the IDE
you'll be able to discover available
api's like the google cloud vision API
at The Associated client library to your
build automatically and even do things
like enable the API on your cloud
project in setup authentication like
creating server
accounts attaching roles to it so you
don't have to switch over to the web
console great so I'm gonna hand it off
to Ian now to kick off the demo all
right so hopefully at this point you
guys aren't sick of us talking yet we're
gonna talk for just one more slide real
quick to give you
oops let's go the right direction there
to give you a quick overview of what
we're gonna demo on our applications so
you have an idea about what we're doing
when we're talking about it so you see
this kind of square with rounded edges
there this is just a cluster and in this
case we're gonna be using gke but you
could realistically use anything it just
needs to be a kubernetes cluster it's
Hahn's gonna use docker for desktop you
could use mini cube you could use a
cluster on Azure AWS it really doesn't
matter it just needs to be a cluster and
in that cluster we have two kind of sets
of service you see the bookshelf which
is just a bookshelf application you can
add a book to it and we'll talk a little
bit about that later on as well as an
image recognition service and what that
does is it does some smarts to make our
bookshelf application a little bit
cooler the bookshelf app is talking to
some data services on GCP to help us
store some data and the image
recognition service is also talking to
some API is around vision and some books
which pretty cool API to get some
information about books so that's just a
quick high-level overview of what's
happening there and now we're gonna go
ahead and jump over to the demo cool all
right so we've got vs code here so it
looked like most unions here were vs
code users but quickly
I'll explain for those of you who are
aren't command shift P or ctrl shift B
is gonna open up the command palette so
we're going to be using that throughout
the talk and that gives you a list of
commands you can access and run and for
the instance of this talk we have cloud
code and these are all the contributions
that we've made that you can use in the
browser so for instance if you're a new
user you don't have a cluster you don't
have code set up we can help you get
started and we can start out by I say I
want to create a cluster and I'm just
gonna type create cluster and we can see
here I can easily in the IDE
I can create a gke cluster or even AWS
Roger so if I want to create a cluster
all I do is pop into here I'm gonna fill
out some basic information and then hit
save I'm not gonna do this right now
it'll take a few minutes to go we
already have a cluster set up for us but
it's pretty simple excuse me so once we
had that cluster created I don't have
anything again I can use the command
palette and I can say
cloud code new application and what we
have here is a set of examples of some
simple applications we have hello world
and guestbook the hello world is a very
simple one service micro service
application and then the guestbook is a
couple micro services that's just a
guestbook you can go in you can write
your name and a message and they'll save
it there and we have support for Python
go no js' java.net core just to make
sure that you can start in language
you're comfortable with so if we go here
we'll start with the guestbook nodejs
just to give you an idea of what's in
this application and kind of how you can
get set up so we have the dot idea
folder for the IntelliJ users if you
want to start there and we have the dot
vs code folder for the vs code users and
we have everything set up for you we
have the launch dot JSON so you can see
here's how we're doing our debugging
here's our debug configurations and then
we have some kubernetes manifests some
source it's pretty simple application
and then lastly the last cool thing here
we have is that scaffold file so I Tom
mentioned scaffold earlier and this is
the engine that's kind of powering a lot
of deployments and we'll dive a little
bit more out of this file a little bit
later on so let's go back to my
application and so this is that
bookshelf application that I mentioned
before so it's similar to the guestbook
it has a similar structure they were
actually based off the original sample
so we have it here let's just go ahead
and deploy it so I'm gonna go back to
the command palette and I'm just gonna
say cloud code and deploy and we see
here we have two different types of
deployments we have deploy and
continuous deploy and continuous deploy
is what it on was talking about this is
the deployment when I hit deploy I'm
going to put in my dev cluster it's
gonna do a deployment and then it's
gonna sit and wait it's gonna wait for
me to do changes to my application so I
don't have to worry about it you see it
building the image it's pushing it and
already it's rolled out and I can go
view that endpoint so I'm gonna go view
it and here's my bookshelf application
so I'm gonna go ahead and add a book
just to give your idea of what happens
here let's go ahead and say the title of
our book kubernetes up and running who's
read that before okay you guys should
read that book it's a really good book
it's written by Kelsey Brendan and Joe I
don't really remember when it was
published the description if I remember
was a super cool book and then we can
choose the image the cover image so
here's the cover image communities up in
running and I'm gonna hit okay and then
I'm gonna save it and then like that
we've got our book and we can go back
and we have our bookshelf that's pretty
cool i've got my description when i
click into it I have a little bit more
stuff so me being the book lover I am
I'm gonna go back to vs code and I'm
gonna say every time that I upload a
book I want the description to say Ian
really likes this book like it's spell
there we go
typing in front of people so hard right
and as soon as I hit save we can see
here that we've already kicked off
another build so I'm not doing anything
I'm saving my code I'm working and the
deployments are happening now what I
want you to remember is that this is not
local this is happening against the gke
cluster so it doesn't feel like I'm
having to do anything special and I'm
just working with that deployment
remotely so while this is building I'm
gonna go ahead and go back to that
scaffold file like I promised you so
here's the scaffold file and so what we
have is we have a default deployment at
the top and then we have profiles and we
can think about profiles they're kind of
like environments so we have a dev
environment and a QA environment and you
can see here our build artifact when we
do nothing special we're just gonna use
docker to do these builds and then we
have a deploy step and we're using cube
CTL we can actually do other things like
customize and helm in here and then we
have the manifests we want to use to
build it when we jump down to QA again
we have that same build here but now
we're using Google cloud build so we're
using Google cloud build we're gonna
build our our images often the server to
give us a little bit more reliable
consistent employment when we're working
with our QA and again you see down here
we have another deploy definition and at
the top we're using dev here and QA down
here at the bottom so now it looks like
my my application has been deployed so
we'll go back over here and I'm gonna go
back to the books and I'm gonna try and
add another book will do kubernetes up
and running again I still don't remember
what was published hopefully we can
figure that out later with something a
tunnel do and then I'm gonna go and use
that again great so now every time I
also added Ian
like this book and of course I didn't
have a space but you can see here how
easy it was for me to change my
application change my code and just
deploy right away so what I did what't
on did we talked about in the beginning
was the image recognition service that
he wrote so being the semi lazy
engineers we were we didn't have to type
all this stuff in I can't remember when
a books been created published I
probably can't spell the author's last
names so I'm gonna go with this and we
call this the auto awesome feature
because we think it's pretty cool and
all I have to do now is I have to go to
that book and I open it up and they'll
pull all the information it needs from
cloud vision and then I can't grab
additional information from a books API
so I'm gonna hit save and this is gonna
take a little bit longer than normal
because it's calling some extra api's in
the backend taking some time to process
the image and now of course now that I'm
sitting here talking to you I realized
this is probably taking a little bit
longer than it should so I'm gonna go
ahead and stop this request go back to
my bookshelf okay we still have the two
books we had before but something's not
right so now's a good time to
demonstrate our debugging capability so
we're gonna go over to our debugger and
all we're gonna do is we're gonna hit to
bug and this was that launched JSON file
I showed you guys originally and just
like that in our terminal there we go
and the debugger is attached one click
in matter of seconds we handle all the
port forwarding for you making sure
we're selecting the right pods and
everything so let's go ahead and go to
our this is the right here the method
that does happens when we do our post
requests to add a book and I'm just
gonna start adding a couple of
breakpoints in here and see if we catch
anything funny there's the auto awesome
feature you can see in the code and just
to be safe let's catch on all cut
exceptions alright so I'm gonna go back
here I'm gonna try that again Auto
awesome
add my book and I'm going to hit save
and just like that we hit a breakpoint
alright in our application so again one
more time this is all happening on a
remote cluster and it doesn't really
feel like I'm doing anything different
so we'll start stepping through this and
see if anything's happening okay was
created by an anonymous user that's fine
we weren't signed in we have a public
image URL that's great I
probably should remove that before I
deployed a QA I don't think their QA
engineers would like that and let's see
here we're inside the auto awesome
feature and just like that unable to
open a file and we can see up here
because I turned catching all uncut
exceptions on we have a failure request
to image wreck 8080 failed so that's
because I'm working in my local
development cluster and it's just my
cluster no one else has access to it
andit on hasn't deployed the service he
wrote to it so we kind of know what the
issue is our Auto awesome feature isn't
working because it's just not there so
I'm gonna go ahead and I'm gonna stop
this debugger and I'm going to do a
quick deploy a single deploy to our QA
cluster and while that's kicking off I'm
gonna go ahead and let Eitan take over
and hopefully he can create the right
image recognition service and we can
link the two up and have a great product
thanks a ton to you cool great can we
switch over to demo two please okay
there we go
so I'm gonna switch over to IntelliJ
right now I have IntelliJ IDEA open not
happen to be using Java to build this
service let's go into configure plugins
really quick so you can see here we have
the cloud code plugin installed this is
now publicly available in the
marketplace and just to point out this
works with all of the JetBrains IDs so
if you're a Python user for example this
will work with PyCharm goal and so I
started working on this service before
the demo and I have it deployed to cloud
source repositories which is Google's
hosted git repos so I'm gonna clone it
from there I'm gonna clone the repo from
there let's clone it into a local folder
it's called image rec and a clone it
okay so it's cloning it right now from
cloud source repos and it's prompting me
to open the project there we go
so the project is now open and
immediately you can see a couple prompts
so this is a maven project and it
detected upon so I'm going to add it
just so that everything syncs and you
can see another prompt here it detected
that this is a kubernetes ready project
and it's prompting me to create a couple
of run configurations so I'm going to
accept that and then immediately here
you see a couple new target
available and these are analogous to the
commands in the command palette that Ian
showed you earlier in vs code we have
deploy and develop deploy does a single
deployment to kubernetes and that's it
develop runs through the whole pipeline
deploys your application but then stays
open and watches for changes in your
source and then redeploys every time
things change we'll see that in a second
so let's just quickly look at the
structure of this project so like I said
this is a maven project happens to be a
spring boot map we have this scaffold
llamó here in got into it a little bit
we have to build strategy defined here
pointing to our artifacts we have the
deploy strategy here as well using coop
control and pointing to our kubernetes
manifests so we have a couple manifests
here one used for dev and one used for
the QA environment the dev adds some
secrets for acting for mounting the
service account axis the remote API so
let's look at our source so we have a
simple controller here let's first set
up the JDK so everything resolves there
we go so we have a couple endpoints here
so we have an image end point this is
the end point that the bookshelf
application is going to hit and then a
couple debug end points that I'm using
just to show you what's going on in the
application we'll see that in a second
and we have a service here called the
default feature extraction service and
this is the service that's responsible
for calling out to the cloud vision API
as well as the books API to do some
extraction from the book image and you
can see there's a lot of class path
issues here these all look like classes
that are part of the cloud vision API
that's okay that means that I can show
you some other features now that we have
so I'm going to quickly go to tools and
select cloud code we have a couple
actions here available to us right now
I'm interested in this one so I'm going
to click add cloud libraries and manage
cloud API s so we get this API Explorer
that I talked about earlier and in
particular right now we're interested in
the cloud vision API like I mentioned so
I'm going to select that we get some
information about the API links to
documentation and so on
we select the cloud project so in this
case we're working with the bookshelf
application bookshelf next 2019
you can see here that it's going to add
it to the main module the image rect
module and it's going to use the latest
BOM and what that means it just means
that it's going to pull in the latest
version of the client library so the
cloud vision client library and you can
see some other things here so I'm by a
fault I have selected to enable the API
in the Google cloud platform so I'm
gonna keep that selected otherwise I
would have had to go into the cloud
console and manually enabled it so I'm
going to continue so at this point we
get some authentication tasks here so
creating a service account and
downloading the key I already did this
before the demo so we can skip that step
now except that so it's enabling the API
on the cloud platform right now we get a
prompt here confirming that the library
was added to the palm and it's prompting
me to import the changes to sync with
maven so I'm gonna import that and
hopefully everything resolves now there
we go so just to take a look at what it
did so I just DIF the pond you can see
that it added the right client library
to my built so now the Google Cloud
vision has been API has been imported so
at this point I think we're ready to try
it and run the app and see if everything
works properly so I'm going to use this
develop on kubernetes run configuration
here let's just edit it to quickly look
at some of the settings that are
available so it automatically detected
my scaffold configuration and it's Auto
populated with a couple profiles so
there's always the default profile and I
also had this Google cloud build profile
available to me I'll just stick with the
default profile for now and before I run
it just to point out I'm pointing right
now to docker for desktop just because I
think that's a inefficient way to work
so I have that selected right now so
let's run it in debug mode this way I
can preview some of the debugging
features that we're gonna be putting out
in the upcoming release
so it's running through the whole
pipeline right now what it's going to be
doing is it's going to build my
application it's going to containerize
it it's going to push it out to a
container repository and then it's going
to deploy everything apply the manifest
using goop control so a couple
interesting things here to see so it did
some port forwarding for me so you can
see a port for did the application port
port 8080 which is the default port the
spring boot uses and also interestingly
it did some other things here port
forwarded port 5005 which happens to be
the default debug port used by je DWP
the Java debug wired protocol and it
also injected this language specific
argument for me set it up as an
environment variable and Java tools
options and nowhere in my code or my
configuration that I have to set this up
manually the plug-in took care of
injecting these arguments for me so that
debugging will be set up so then the
spring boot application is loading and
it looks like it's complete at this
point so we can jump over to the web
browser and let's hit that debug
endpoint okay so we just have a simple
form to just debug and make sure things
are working properly so I'm gonna select
this book effective Java it's probably
familiar to you Java developers out
there so I'm going to select that and
I'm gonna upload it so what happened
here I got back some JSON with the
features from the book so the title
description author and publish date but
it doesn't look like it actually got
anything interesting out of the book
this just seems like placeholder text so
that's good we can now debug the
application and figure out what's going
on so let's go into our image upload
controller and set a breakpoint right
before it's about to call the feature
extraction service and see if we can
figure out why it's not getting any real
data here so the breakpoints set I'm
gonna select the same book again and I'm
gonna upload it and you can see it
immediately hit the breakpoint and again
this application is running in docker
for desktop so I'm going to shift f7 and
step into the extract text method to see
okay so I can immediately see what the
problem is here
so it's using this test feature
extraction service which is just a stub
that I made for testing purposes
basically hard-coding the values so
that's not what we want
forgot to inject the right version of
the service so let's step out of that
let's upload this one more time so that
we hit the first breakpoint and at this
point let's cheat a little bit so I'm
going to right-click on the feature
extraction service the local variable
and click set value and let's set it to
the new default feature extraction
service right there so I'm gonna apply
that and it's gonna hot-swap the changes
directly into the running application so
at this point I can step out of it and
hopefully now it's calling the cloud
vision API and it will give me some real
information so there we go so this looks
a little bit better now we got some
information back from the book we got
the title the author in the published
date and just for debugging purposes I'm
showing an annotated image with the
bounding boxes for the features that it
found what's what's happening is it's
basically just using a simple heuristic
to find the title of a book and then
calling out to the books API to get the
remaining information but it looks like
we still have a little bit of a problem
the description here is null so let's go
back and see if we can debug that so I'm
gonna go into my default feature
extraction service and go down to where
it's pulling that description so right
here so it looks like it's it's pulling
the description from this volume and
volume info object so let's upload one
more time so it's this is the original
breakpoint step out of that there we go
so now let's open the expression
evaluator really quick and let's look
and see what's inside a volume info so
volume info is calling get subtitle and
indeed you can see it's returning null
so let's look and see what else is
available here so it looks immediately I
see just get description here looks like
the one we should have been using all
along and we have the real information
here
so let's fix that so I'm just gonna fix
it really quick and at this point I
could wait for everything to rebuild and
redeploy but that's longer than I want
to wait so I'm just going to do control
shift f7 no sorry control shift F 9 and
what that's going to do it's going to
recompile just this class and the ID is
going to detect that the classes changed
and prompt me to reload them so I'm
gonna say yes and so now these changes
were live reloaded into the running
application so now at this point I
should be able to do one last test and
verify that everything is working and of
course we still hit the breakpoint and
there we go so now we have all the
information that we need and we should
be ready to push this application up to
the QA environment to test the
end-to-end integration so let's go back
so I'm done with developing right now so
let's kill this and now we want to push
this up to the QA environment so I'm
gonna switch from docker for desktop and
point to my QA cluster and if you recall
I mentioned that we have these two sets
of kubernetes manifests and currently
the QA manifests are not properly wired
in so we can do that really quick and
open up the scaffold llamó and the way
we're going to do this is we're just
going to add a new profile to point to
the right manifests so I'm gonna use the
editing support so let's add a new
profile and let's call it QA and we're
gonna override the deployment
configuration and we're still gonna use
coop control here but you can see that
you have some other options here some
other deployment strategies if you're
using helm or customize you can use that
so I'm still a coop control and then
manifests and then point to my web QA
manifests so that looks good and I'm
gonna switch over to the deploy to
kubernetes run configuration let's edit
it so it's still pointing to the default
profile but it automatically
did that I created a new profile so I'm
going to select it and let's choose
two-tailed oh excuse me to tail the logs
after deployment in case something goes
wrong so I'm gonna apply that and I'm
just gonna run the single deployment so
it's kicking off the pipeline right now
building everything pushing it out to a
container registry and deploy my
application and while that's running
just to point out you may have noticed
that there's no docker file here
anywhere in this project that's because
I'm using the tool called jib which I
explained a little bit about earlier you
can see here I'm using it in the form of
the jib maven plugin it's as simple as
this gives you a lot of configuration
options but getting started is just as
easy as dropping in this maven plugin
and that'll containerize your
application efficiently without needing
docker and without even needing to write
a docker file so let's check on the
status of our deployment it looks like
it's already complete so that's good
then now let's jump over to the QA
environment so here we are again I'm
gonna choose to add a book and I'm gonna
use this auto awesome feature that Ian
talked about now let's choose the same
book as before and save it and so
hopefully now the bookshelf application
is going to be calling out to my image
recognition service but of course we got
an error because this is a live demo
let's try one more time we got to change
test test to default
oh right thank you so remember that I
had that injection issue where I was
injecting the the test stub version I
forgot to swap that out because we live
reloaded it how you know it's live so
Thank You Ian for catching that so let's
open up the controller really quick and
here we go let's swap it out to the
default service perfect so at this point
I should still be using the QA profile
and let's redeploy again so this should
be pretty quick
so it's gonna build my image looks like
the build was successful and the
deployment was complete so now the
spring boot app is starting and it
should be done in a second now there we
go
all right let's test that out one more
time let's add a book oops
select effective Java again and save it
there we go
this looks like it's taking a little
longer now so it's hopefully calling out
to the right API and there we go we've
extracted all the features from the book
image and we didn't have to type
anything so I think we're happy with our
application right now everything looks
good in the QA environment so I'm gonna
hand it back to Ian to show you some
more cool features in vs code so that's
a good thing if you guys realize how
fast that second build was that was jib
right so that was considerably faster
than the first time to garage it was
able to rebuild the image for you faster
with the existing pieces of docker file
or docker it granularly granularly
layers the image so that it only needs
to rebuild the image the chain so it
splits up your java application into its
dependencies resources and your source
files and only the layer that changed
gets rebuilt so obviously that leads to
a much faster container builds can we go
back to demo one please cool just like
that alright so it's hot and I have
talked through a lot of the developers
story for everyone and you've seen the
developer inner loop and debugging and
how simple we can make that for you so
we're gonna touch a little bit right now
on will be provided for the dev ops side
of things looking at your kubernetes
cluster and looking and working with
some yamo so we're gonna jump right into
it so here we have this contribution
here on the bottom left and we can see
here we have a couple of explorers so
the bottom one we have a Google
Equipment Eddie's Engine Explorer and
this is a pretty simple Explorer it has
my account you can see here the project
Google Cloud project I'm using as well
as the clusters it has the Explorer
itself is pretty simple give you some
creation time some public endpoints the
status of it but what the real power
here is is I can right click and set his
active cluster and that bumps it up to
my cluster Explorer and that's the
explorer up here and this is where we
have all the great features so right now
you can see here I have the QA and my
dev cluster and I'm gonna go ahead and
I'm going to expand my QA cluster and
we're gonna see some information so I'm
looking at the default namespace right
now everything we did we worked in our
default namespace and we can see we have
our deployments pod services even some
custom resource definitions and we can
do this for any namespace we have so if
we go ahead and look at our deployments
you can see here we have our three
deployments deployed right here the
bookshelf front-end and worker as well
as that image recognition service so if
we looked at my dev cluster for instance
we wouldn't see that image recognition
service which is why my original test
failed so we can go ahead and dive into
this a little bit deeper we can see here
our bookshelf front-end it gives us the
desired replica counts we can see here
this little green dot in the corner here
I don't know if it shows up on that
screen as well but that's just kind of
the state of everything if it's green
everything's good if there's some issues
will show a little yellow icon there and
you can dive and look into it and if
there's something that's going wrong you
can definitely go ahead and take a look
at your events so these are events from
the last 24 hours
a lot of the times if something's going
wrong you can go ahead and look at that
and you can see some of the issues just
like that from your IDE so I'm gonna
show you one cool feature here so if I'm
just playing around on a test cluster
dev cluster definitely don't suggest
doing this in production but I want a
viewer edit my MOC I want a couple more
replicas I can just go right here and I
can pull up the Yambol from the server
so this isn't my local local UML this is
my server yamo and I see here I've got
two replicas I changed my mind I want
three I'm gonna save it and it asked me
if I want to apply this configuration
again not necessarily best production
practices but something you can do if
you're playing around you hit yes and
just like that we can go back to our
cluster Explorer and we've got three
replicas so we can easily change and
modify the state of our accumulated
clusters and applications just from the
IDE we can also look a little bit more
in four pods to get some more
Diagnostics about the application we're
working with you can see here now we
have three front-end workers because we
just added one we also have our
bookshelf and the image recognition
from these we can go ahead and view and
stream logs well if I want to view logs
I can see the logs that came from from
this pod and we can see here we had a
couple requests this there wasn't too
much traffic sent to it but we have our
post and our get and we can kind of see
what's happening there and if we want to
dive a little bit deeper we can see
here's our bookshelf application I can
even get a terminal into that pod into
that container and you can see here I'm
just gonna do a quick LS and you can see
here all these files here is basically
just what I had in my Explorer here and
it Able's enables me to be able to dive
a little bit deeper into what's
happening and be right where my
application is running so we go back to
our Explorer here we can of course take
a look at our services replicas sets
config maps but we're able to easily see
the state of our applications dive in
and change them a little bit if we want
so onto the yeah Milles the set of
features we have for our yeah Mille so
we know that Y amel is a little bit
difficult there's a lot of it when you
start using kubernetes maybe you add it
on K native and sto and customize and
now you just have piles of yeah Mille
and one of the things we wanted to try
and do was help make that experience
easier for the user so right here this
is our our deployment it's a bookshelf
worker deployment you can see here
whenever I want to see what's going on
and see what what one thing is I can
never keep these in my head so a spec
what's supposed to go on a spec there's
quite a few things here so we just not
hover give you the ability to see all
the definitions and potential fields and
we can do this for any of these and
they'll give me an idea it's it should
be a string it gives me a short
description and on top of that since we
know that information we can give you
some completion so if I want to add
something I can get a list of all the
possibilities here as well as the
definitions for them so I know what I'm
adding and how I'm adding it and again
we can do some even more smarts we know
that a replicas is probably going to be
an integer if we hover over this I'm
guessing it'll tell me it's an integer
and say we go ahead and change this to
cloud code cloud code should not be a
valid set of replicas and we can see
here we're getting an error it's
incorrect type and so we can do some
type checking to help it'll help you a
little bit along the way and of course
vs code will give us these nice red
not happy passing we can change that
back and so one of my absolute favorite
things that we can do here in our in our
yeah Mille is we have some insight into
what's happening at the server or local
level so you see here we have a config
map defined at the bottom and you see it
there's a little hover above it that
says created four days ago so the first
time this was created on my cluster was
four days ago and I can dive into this a
little bit so it's a config folder it's
a name config folder and I can peek the
definition of that and what happens is I
pop up a window here and you can see
here this is the local definition of
this on my machine so I can see my
config map is here the name is config
folder this is what we peek the
definition of and then I have a project
ID which is my Google Cloud project ID
and if I want to see what's going on
again with this at the server level I
can go dive into that too and so here's
my server version of it this is what's
on my active cluster right now and I can
look in this we can see scaffold adds
some labels when it does its deployments
we can see our last applied
configuration and we can even if we go
back to our local file I want to make
some changes I can just go ahead and
click onto that and it takes me right to
my code to my Y amyl in the IDE so I'm
more easily able to work with my Y amyl
and navigate around it so these are all
the features we have here for you on the
DevOps side of things if you want to see
a little bit more about this later we
have another talk coming up we'll tell
you about that doesn't much deeper dive
into some of these features let's just
quickly recap what we just saw so first
we worked on the bookshelf application
which was a two service app had a front
end and a back end and we saw how easy
it was to set up this div this local
development workflow this inner
development loop the single click we
were able to set up this this
development workflow where the apple
where the extension would monitor for
changes in your source and then surface
then live on the cluster and remember
the application was running on GK in
that case on Ian's dev cluster and you
also saw you in with a single click
attach a debugger to the application and
step through it and it behaved as if the
application we're running locally was
just as easy as that
we then switched over to IntelliJ to
build the image recognition service and
which happens to be in Java we should do
much of the same
shonali for the inner development loop
additionally we showed you debugging the
application which was running in docker
for desktop and making changes to a
class file and then live reloading them
hot swapping them right into the running
application drastically reducing the
iteration cycle time next we showed you
some ops types features so digging into
your cluster looking at your pods seeing
some events streaming logs from
containers viewing remote llamó and that
kind of thing
and lastly we showed you some
functionality some editing support for
dealing with all of your llamo
configuration so what's next well first
we would love for all of you to try out
these tools and file issues if you find
them on github and make feature requests
and we plan to continue building out our
kubernetes support so more direct
support for tools like helm and
customized in in the plugins and more
support for Google cloud platform
products like integrations with things
like cloud build at this point you might
be wondering how to get your hands on
these tools and Ian will tell you cool
thanks it's on so the good stuff how do
we get to it so we've got the visual
studio extension cloud code for visual
studio code is in the vs code
marketplace you can go ahead and
download it
cloud code for IntelliJ is in the
JetBrains repository plugins repository
and we have our documentation
cloud.google.com slash code that QR code
will take you straight to the docs and
from our Doc's you can get links to our
issue tracking feature requests things
like that and I want to stress what aton
said is if you have feature requests
ideas thoughts please go ahead and leave
them for us it's a new product we're
still developing it and we're building
it for you for the developers for the
DevOps so we want you to be happy with
the product we want you to have the
features in it that you want to be
successful in your jobs so we greatly
accept feedback so back to it on great
well thank you everyone that concludes
our talk we have some related talks that
we can recommend if you're interested in
diving deeper yet mention the first one
dead easy kubernetes workflows with vs
code which we'll dive a little bit
deeper into these workflows using the vs
code extension it's tomorrow
11 a.m. if you're interested in that and
we have another talk that we can
recommend that will show you a little
bit more with the Google container tools
that we have available and working with
cloud builds and that's also tomorrow at
11:00 a.m. and we have our information
up here so if any questions come up
later feel free to reach out to us and
we'll do our best to get back to you and
thanks everyone for coming
[Applause]
[Music]